يتعرض اذا تطبيق تيك توك الذي تملكه شركه
بايت دانس الصينيه لتهديدا كبيرا من
الولايات المتحده بمنعه خصوصا بعد تخيير
اداره الرئيس جو بايدن للشركه بين ان
تتخلى عن ملكيتها الصينيه او تواجه حظرا
تاما كاغلب المنصات الاجتماعيه المملوكه
للولايات المتحده يوتيوب وفيسبوك
وانستجرام يجمع تطبيق تيك توك جميع انواع
البيانات عن كل مستخدم ومن خلال
خوارزمياته يستخدم بل يستخدم هذه
المعلومات لعرض مزيد من الامور التي تهم
المستخدمين ولكن ينظر الى التطبيق على انه
الاكثر تقدما والاكثر فعاليه بشكل غير
متوقع في التعرف على اهتمامات المستخدمين
شركه تيك توك الصينيه مثيره للقلق بشكل
خاص في الولايات المتحده حيث يقضي مستخدم
التطبيق الامريكيون سته وخمسين دقيقه في
يوميا عليه اي اكثر بكثير مما يقضونه على
فيسبوك او انستجرام يتخوف منتقدون تيك توك
من امكانيه تسريب بيانات مستخدمي تطبيق في
الولايات المتحده الى الحكومه الصينيه
وتقول واشنطن الى هذه البيانات قد تستخدم
بهدف التجسس على الامريكيين او لنشر
الدعايه اداره التطبيق اعلنت انها انفقت
اكثر من مليار ونصف المليار دولار على ما
تسميه الجهود الصارمه لامن البيانات تحت
اسم مشروع تكساس وتصر تيك توك على ان
التطبيق لا يعمل بشكل مختلف عن منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الاخرى وتقول انها لن
تمتثل اطلاقا لاي امر بنقل البيانات الى
سلطات بيجين ان طلب من ذلك
ينضم الينا اذا الان من واشنطن جودي ويسبي
مديره شركه المخاطر الدوليه للانترنت
والامن السيبراني سيده جودي مرحبا بك هل
تتجه السلطات الامريكيه الى حظر التطبيق
فعلا
يا سيدي نعم نعم اعتقد ان الكونجرس
بالاضافه الى البيت الابيض يتجهون نحو
فرضي حظر لا اعتقد ان جلسه الاستماع قد
غيرت من موقفهم او رايهم لكن هل يمكن
بالفعل فرض هذا الحظر
نعم نحن
قمنا بفرض
على استخدام هذا التطبيق من قبل
الموظفين وايضا العديد من الولايات قامت
بذلك وكندا ايضا قامت بنفس الامر بالتالي
باستطاعتنا ان نقول ان هذا التطبيق يمكن
ان يكون محظورا في الولايات المتحده هذا
التطبيق محظور في الصين هو ليس متوفرا
للاستخدام في الصين ده في داخل الصين
وعليه ماذا سيكون باعتقادك
مستقبل تيك توك ما هو مصير هذا التطبيق
الذي يحظى بكل هذه الجماهيريه الواسعه حول
العالم
هو يتمتع بشعبيه كبيره لكن اعتقد انه اما
عليه ان يقوم
يقوم باجراء تعديلات ربما او ربما لن يتم
سماح باستخدامه في الولايات المتحده
الضمانات
السياسه التي يتبعها لم تطمن تطمن الساسه
كانوا كم يطلب البيانات المستخدمين
السلطات الصينيه لكن حسب سياسات التطبيق
فان الشركات عليها ان تتعاون مع الحكومات
الحكومات التي التي ياتي منها التطبيق
وبالتالي ربما بوبيت قد يحل محل تيك توك
او ربما قد يكون هنالك ربما تعديل في
السياسه لكن اعتقد انه سيكون هنالك مع ذلك
بعض الق يود المفروضه عليهما لم يتم تغيير
السياسه الحقيقيه له لماذا لم تقتنع
السلطات الامريكيه بما قاله رئيس مجلس
اداره تيك توك بانه لن يجري باي حال من
الاحوال مشاركه البيانات لدى التطبيق مع
السلطات الصينيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حكومه اجنبيه بالتالي هذا التمييز بين
التطبيقات الاخرى مثل فيسبوك او تطبيقات
اخرى والتي لها قواعد هنا في الولايات
المتحده بالتالي ليس لديهم مشكله في تسليم
هذه البيانات الى الحكومه الامريكيه طيب
هذا التطبيق يستخدمه اكثر من 150 مليون
امريكي يقدون
الدقائق كثيره عليه خلال اليوم اكثر من ما
يقضونه على باقي التطبيقات بالتالي هذا
يشكل اقتصادا بحد ذاته جرى حظر هذا
التطبيق ما هو مصير هذا الاقتصاد الدائر
على تيك توك
ربما اجراء تعديلات او انه قد يكون هنالك
تطبيقات منافسه تحل محل اعتقد ان ما سيحدث
انه
قد يكون
هنالك هنالك نقطه
نحضر منها لان الحكومه الصينيه ربما تخبر
تخبرهم انهم لا يمكنهم ان يكون هذا الامر
ممكنا وبالتالي قد يحدث نوعا من المواجهه
بين الحكومه الامريكيه والحكومه الصينيه
شكرا لك من موشن تانجودي وسبي مديره شركه
المخاطر الدوليه للانترنت والامن
السيبراني